قصه نجاح توجت بتسجيل السعوديه لاول فائضا
منذ 2013 في ميزانيه العام الجاري جاء
افضل من التوقعات السابقه ليبلغ 100 مليار
ريال ويمثل 2016 في المئه من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي ياتي الفائده على خلفيه
ايرادات بلغت
2434 مليار تشكل الارادات غير النفطيه 32%
منها قبلها نفقات بترليونيون
و232 مليار ريال اما الميزانيه الجديده
لعام 2023
فستشهدوا تحقيقه ثاني فائده على التوالي
عند 16 مليار ريال يمثل 14% من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي وفي التفاصيل تقدر
الارادات للعمل المقبل مثل اليونان و 130
مليار ريال مقابل نفر فقط مثل اليونان و14
مليار ومن ناحيه النمو الاقتصادي في
السعوديه فهو الاسرع بندول مجموعه العشرين
بعد ان جاء عند 8.5% اما خلال العمل مقبل
فمن المتوقع نمو الاقتصاد بثلاثه فاصله
واحد في المئه مدعوما بالانشطه النفطيه
ليرتفع بعدها الى خمسه وسبعه عشر في المئه
في 2024 هذا وسيسجل التضخم في السعوديه
2016 في المئه هذا العام لينخفض الى اثنين
فاصله واحد في المئه في 2030 2020
سياده الدين العام تماشت خلال هذه السنوات
مع التطورات في تحضير الميزانيه العامه
فمحفظه الدين العام تصل اليوم الى 985
مليار ريال لتقاربه
25% من النتيجه المحلي
وقد ازدادت المديونيه ضمن خطه لوزاره
الماليه لضمان بناء علاقه مع اسواق الدين
تسمح للم بالاستدانه في اوقات الحاجه
وايضا في اوقات الرخاء مايا جريديني
العربيه